imagine a giant spaceship lands in your
backyard
the door flings open and you are invited
inside
to see what you can learn now the
technology clearly is
millions of years beyond what we can
make right now
well this spaceship is biology
here on earth life itself in fact is a
technology that has been evolving for
billions of years
and in this video we will explore how it
works
and discover some of the amazing things
that it could enable
in the near future so since the start of
the global coronavirus pandemic
i started a completely new adventure
into the fields of
computational biology and protein
engineering
to try and understand how these complex
nano machines
function and after working in this field
for quite some time now i wanted to
share some of the amazing things i've
learned
because my audience of computer science
people which is you guys
are in a unique position to make
incredibly valuable contributions
to one of the most promising areas of
modern science
so this series will contain several
parts in this first video i want to
start by building up a general
understanding
of the physical processes that underpin
our biology
going from the genetic code embedded in
our dna to the insane world of proteins
covering the basic mechanics of the
coronavirus
and introducing emerging fields like ai
assisted
computational biology now i'm doing this
because you can't really dive into the
machine learning aspects of this field
without at least having a basic
understanding of the biology that's
involved
i mean i learned a ton of fascinating
stuff over the past year
and so i try to condense as much of that
as possible
into this video the next videos then
will focus on specific machine learning
techniques and architectures
that are becoming ever more prominent in
this quickly evolving field
we'll look at various challenges like
for example property prediction for a
given molecular structure
the famous protein folding problem in
deep mind's alpha fold
and introduce the exciting emerging
field of ai
driven molecular design so if you're
eager to set your first steps into one
of the most promising areas of modern
science
i hope you're ready to dive in deep my
name is xander and welcome back
to archive insights
so what are proteins and why should i
care
well the very first thing that i'd like
you to contemplate is that
you and i in fact every living
biological entity on this planet
is in essence an incredibly complicated
and
interconnected molecular machine
and what i mean by this is that every
process
inside our bodies no matter how
complicated or how
magical it may seem they're all governed
by the same laws of nature
that we study in fields like chemistry
and elementary physics
and now the reason that these simple
natural laws give rise to the enormous
complexity of life
is that over billions of years of
evolution the tiny atomic particles that
make up our universe
well they started coalescing into ever
more complex formations that gradually
diversified
and started interacting with one another
now there are many
open questions in this field of
evolutionary chemistry or abiogenesis as
it's called
but what we do know is that at some
point in the evolution of life
simple organic molecules started forming
small
self-replicating systems which then
became subject to random mutations in
natural selection
and over billions of years these systems
gradually diversified and produced
more familiar biological elements like
cell barriers
genetic material and the ability to
capture ever more energy from their
environment
through processes like photosynthesis
for example
now to get an even richer appreciation
of this miracle of life
i think it's useful to get a sense of
scale with respect to the concept that
we'll be talking about in these videos
so if we start out with a small object a
familiar size let's say a coffee bean or
a grain of rice
that measures several millimeters across
and we gradually zoom in
well we soon encounter things like
amoeba which are
fairly large but unicellular organisms
going deeper we encounter things like
the human egg cell and sperm cell
measuring
several micrometers across next let's
dive
inside these cells and look at what
they're made of here we find things like
the chromosome which is
essentially a huge storage container for
our dna inside the nucleus
of every living cell next we find things
like
bacteria for example here the
mitochondria which are like
the power plants inside of our cells
they burn sugar molecules
to produce atp which is the main unit of
chemical energy
that is used to power all other
processes going on
in the cell's interior and if we zoom in
even more we have to start measuring
things in nanometers
so this is already about a million times
smaller
than the millimeter size of the coffee
bean that we started from
here we encounter viruses that are so
small that they can easily penetrate
into our cells and start affecting their
function
by injecting their own genetic material
into the machinery of the cell
essentially they're hijacking our own
molecular factories
to produce copies of the virus and in
this sense the computer analogy is a
pretty good one
the virus doesn't have any hardware to
produce copies of itself
its only way to spread is to infect a
host cell
and use its hardware to make copies of
itself and finally if we zoom
in beyond the scale of the smallest
viruses
we encounter the domain of proteins
proteins are essentially small nano
machines that perform
very specific functions inside of living
organisms
here for example you can see depiction
of what's called a ribosome
it's a complex molecular machine found
in all living cells
that essentially translates the genetic
code written in our dna
and uses it to produce new proteins
but before we take a closer look at how
exactly all of this works let's first
finish our biological zoom all the way
to the bottom
here's another protein called hemoglobin
and its function is very simply to
capture oxygen molecules in our lungs
and transport them across the body
releasing them
inside our cells where they are needed
for breaking down the sugars
in the mitochondria that we just saw and
then finally if we dive below the
nanometer scale
we arrive at the very smallest
biological compounds
like glucose and adenine that are made
up of just a few individual atoms
so the main thing to remember here is
that all of biology is a tremendously
complex hierarchy of
interacting systems each of which is
following the laws of nature
but gaining complexity as we move up the
scale ladder
in theory with an infinitely powerful
computer
you could solve all open questions about
biology
by simply simulating a living system
down to the atom level
so now that we have an idea of the
various components
that play a role in this molecular dance
let's take a look at some of the most
fundamental processes in this play of
life
specifically we'll start by taking a
look at how
exactly the genetic code embedded in our
dna
contains the executive program on which
all of these processes run so buckle
your seat belt as we dive into the most
fundamental process that powers life on
earth
so deep inside the nucleus of every cell
in our body we find
the chromosomes they're essentially huge
storage containers
for our genetic material humans actually
have 46 of these chromosomes which
together contain what is called the
human genome or in other words
the molecular blueprint that contains
all the information that you need
to build a human body now the genetic
material
inside of those chromosomes is tightly
wrapped around proteins called
histones to keep things nice and tidy if
it weren't for those histones
the long dna strand would become a
completely
tangled mess now what happens when our
cell
needs to build new machinery is that a
specific section of this dna
called a gene will be read for
instructions on how to produce
a specific protein the whole process
starts with an already existing protein
called
rna polymerase that latches onto the dna
and unwinds the double helix into a flat
section of genetic code using its
complex machinery it will then start to
copy the instructions encoded in the dna
sequence
in a process called transcription now in
this phase
each letter of the gene is faithfully
copied over into a complementary chain
of base pairs
that essentially contains the same
information as the gene itself
the result of this transcription is a
chain of messenger
rna which contains the relevant part of
the genetic code
that's needed to create a specific
protein
and once this is done the messenger rna
moves
out of the nucleus and travels into the
cytoplasm of the cell
there it encounters another type of
proteins called
ribosomes which are like the protein
factories of our cells
so where the dna polymerase are the guys
that figure out exactly
how to build proteins the ribosomes
actually get the job done
so the ribosome binds to this messenger
rna and it starts
reading its instructions in order to
produce a new protein
now the fundamental building blocks of
proteins
are what are called amino acids these
are
small molecular compounds that come in
unique flavors
and they consist of only about 10 to 20
atoms so
these things are really really small in
fact there are exactly 20 different
types of amino acids in ordinary biology
which you can think of as the essential
lego pieces
that biology uses to make stuff it's
like
the fundamental alphabet of life freely
floating around in the cytoplasm of the
cell every one of these amino acids
is connected to a piece of transfer rna
which contains a unique identifier at
the bottom that
perfectly matches a specific
three-letter sequence
in the genetic code the ribosome reads
the messenger rna
three bases at a time and as each
triplet is read
the connected transfer rna delivers
the corresponding lego block to a
growing
chain of amino acids that exits the
ribosome at the top
and after the last amino acid has been
added the purposefully ordered chain
is then released into the cytoplasm of
the cell's interior
which is essentially full of water
molecules
there it is subject to a complex
interaction of physical forces both
among the amino acids in the chain
as well as with the surrounding water
molecules and this
finally causes the entire chain to fold
in on itself
and to form a complex but unique
three-dimensional structure
which is called a protein and that's why
this
entire process is called translation
because through this beautifully complex
mechanism
the molecular engine of life is able to
translate
a piece of genetic code into an
operational protein
that can now go and take up its own
proper function
somewhere else in the body all right so
we've just seen
that the ordering of the dna letters in
the gene that we start from
controls the ordering of the amino acid
sequence in the protein chain
and after that the laws of physics cause
that chain to
fold up into the lowest energy state
that it can reach
in fact this is exactly what people mean
when they talk about protein
folding and it's exactly this task that
deepmind's alpha fold model addresses
essentially
deepmind trained a carefully designed
neural network architecture
to predict the three-dimensional shape
of a protein
knowing only its amino acid sequence
they did this using a very large data
set of known protein structures which is
called
the protein data bank or pdb and
given that this approach recently
started to work amazingly well
it's actually opening up an incredibly
exciting
area of ai assisted protein design which
is the space that i'm working in right
now
but we will talk a lot more about that
in future videos in fact
once deepind eventually releases their
academic alpha phil2 paper
hopefully with code and models included
i intend to make an
entire video dedicated to protein
folding
all right fair enough so a protein has a
unique
shape that's entirely defined by its
amino acid sequence
which is coded up in our dna but why
should that have
anything to do with a protein's function
you might ask
well a good intuitive way to think about
this is to imagine proteins as small
three-dimensional puzzle pieces
that fit into certain pockets but don't
fit in most
others additionally many of these
proteins are not
really fixed rigid structures but they
can actually
change shape depending on what they're
chemically bound
to to give a concrete example of this
let's take a look
at a very specific pair of two proteins
that absolutely blew my mind when i
first learned about them
so i'm talking about the motor protein
pair consisting of
dynein and kinesin and the main function
of these motor proteins
is to move stuff around inside of the
cell
so it turns out that pretty much every
cell in your body
contains what are called microtubules
which are essentially long cables that
are stretched between
opposite sides of the cell barrier now
these microtubules they function as
rigid structural highways that the
dynein and kinesin proteins
interact with in order to move stuff
around
in your cells and the way this works is
that kinesin for example consists of
two identical motor heads at one end
and a long and flexible organelle at the
other that attaches to the cargo
that's being moved around now the shape
of the motor heads
is such that when it comes into contact
with a microtubule
it establishes a strong chemical bond
which releases a small adp molecule
from the now attached head and almost
instantaneously then this
empty binding site is filled up by an
atp
molecule which triggers a shape change
of the motor head
causing the other leg to be thrown
forward and
also bind to the microtubule and when
this happens
it triggers a chemical reaction in the
first head
which causes it to let go of the
microtubule
and the process loops back from the
beginning
essentially causing the kinesin motor to
start
walking along the microtubule track
with its two alternating legs and
pulling along anything that's attached
to it i mean
is it isn't that just absolutely
incredible
and these proteins actually do a lot
more than just
carry around stuff within cells in fact
similar kinds of proteins are
responsible for any kind of
muscle contraction in your body i mean
just think about this for a second every
time that you move a muscle in your body
millions of these tiny molecular engines
purposefully
designed by the genetic code in our dna
instantly
react to an electrical signal coming
from your brain
and they start changing shape and
physically
interacting with other proteins causing
your
muscle fibers to contract in your body
to move
also interesting is that relative to
their size
these motor proteins move about as fast
as an
actual car on a highway but they are
four
times more efficient than your car in
converting chemical energy
into motion so you see i mean we still
have a lot left to learn from mother
nature
so what you should remember is that the
driving mechanism of protein function
is the chemical interactions that they
have with other substrates in the body
and the way that these interactions
happen is
largely controlled by their shape so to
give a second example of why
shape is so important in the protein
world let's take a look
at the biggest biological nemesis of
recent times
the coronavirus so the coronavirus
is a single encased cell surrounded on
the outside
with the so-called spike protein which
gives the virus its crown-like look
and hence its name now because of its
shape
this spike protein has a particular
affinity
to binding with a specific protein in
the human body
which is the ace2 receptor on the
surface of human lung cells
so what happens is that the virus is
just roaming around in the body
until it encounters some lung cells
where the spike
protein then binds with this h2 receptor
this then triggers a protein-powered
shape
change whereby the viral rna enters the
human cell
and it hijacks our own cellular
machinery
to start making copies of the virus
fortunately
the protein mechanism that makes viruses
so dangerous
is also their weakness think about the
capsid on the outside
as a three-dimensional fingerprint that
uniquely identifies each type of virus
in fact this is exactly how our body is
able to mount a defense against the
virus attack
by purposefully manufacturing antibodies
that bind to the capsid of a specific
virus
our adaptive immune system can create a
highly targeted defense
and if you're lucky your immune system
will remember how to make those specific
antibodies for many years to come
which is precisely what we call being
immune this
is also how a lot of vaccines work you
simply
manufacture some of those capsid
proteins in a lab
and you inject them into the patient
without an actual virus being present
the immune system will detect this
strange compound and it will start
creating specific antibodies that binds
to that protein signature
so that when the virus actually comes
around our body can mount a highly
specialized attack almost
instantaneously
so i think by now it's becoming clear
why ai models like deepmind's alpha fold
have such an
incredible impact on areas like drug
development and vaccine design
because if we can use ai to predict the
structures of most important proteins in
biology
and model their interactions well this
gives us
amazing new insights to how they
function looking
at the future then many people agree
that this is the beginning of an
entirely
new era in computational biology
as ai continues to get better at
modeling the complexity
of the real world it will open up new
opportunities to cure
incurable diseases treat cancer and will
likely become a core component
of any biomedical design cycle there is
also tremendous potential
in a field called bioengineering that
tries to harness the efficient molecular
mechanisms that nature discovered
through evolution motor proteins for
example are four
times as efficient in converting
chemical energy into motion
compared to a regular gasoline engine so
what if we could engineer an engine
based on motor proteins
and all it would take to run was a
little bit of sugar
or what if we could use living cells to
grow
new organic materials with exceptional
properties like we see in bamboo or
tooth enamel there's even people working
on designing new enzymes that can
actually break up
environmental waste materials like hard
plastics
that are not traditionally biodegradable
needless to say that with the
ever-growing amount of available data
and the sheer complexity
of the processes involved machine
learning is positioned
as a very powerful tool for many of
these scientific disciplines
so in the next few videos we'll dive
into some of the specifics of how to
apply
deep learning to various areas of
computational biology
like protein structure prediction
protein design property prediction
and much more so whether you look at it
from a purely scientific perspective or
you're more of an instinctive type of
person
life is undoubtedly the most astounding
miracle in the universe
and we are smack in the middle of it so
the next time you're getting some corona
blues
just look at your own hand and
contemplate you know the astounding
complexity
of molecular machinery that is hard at
work
to keep you very much alive all right
and before ending this video i wanted to
quickly mention that
i'm trying out a new platform called
pensite where i'm available for
one-on-one video calls in case you have
questions about specific projects
that you're working on or any kind of
machine learning question in general
link is in the description hope to see
you there
you